[Music]
okay I see how it works when I don't
like Thor the dark world it's oh you
don't understand Thor natalie portman
the kat dennings are amazing oh you just
don't get it
but then when thor ragnarok comes around
it's oh we finally got a good Thor movie
all no Natalie Portman or Kant dennings
oh they finally understand blow me you
symbolic voice I've decided to clump all
of the internet I don't like into anyway
Thor Ragnarok is a funny big epic
action-packed fun time it's not
especially deep or very meaningful but
it finally gives us a story and visuals
that look on par with what Thor was or
at the very least an eighties rock cover
which is what Thor should be damn it
after returning from a giant mission
Thor discovers that Loki his brother has
disguised himself as Odin and he forces
him to change back when he demands Loki
to take him to his real father they find
he doesn't have much time left
in a quick change of tone that's
surprisingly effective we see him slowly
fade away while also giving information
about their actual firstborn pella the
banished rightful heir is going to come
and reclaim her throne the minute he
died and seeing how he told them this
the minute he died they don't have much
time to prepare and she comes in attacks
she and her army banished Thor and Loki
to another realm where they're used as
entertainment a part of the galaxy of
gladiators video bounty hunters and Jeff
Goldblum because somehow strangely this
movie feels naked without him Thor is
captured to fight for ruler Goldblum's
amusement and wouldn't you know it one
of the other captured gladiators is the
Hulk the problem is though the Hulk has
stayed the Hulk for a long time he
hasn't turned back human in quite a
while so Thor has a lot on his plate he
has to turn the Hulk back to himself
escaped defeat his sister and also
stopped Ragnarok the destruction of his
entire kingdom so it's quite a lot to
throw at you in one movie and smartly
the film doesn't take it too seriously
sometimes I can be a problem as there's
an occasional joke that almost doesn't
feel very Thor aligned but we're used to
that from the other Thor movies honestly
here I almost argue its downplayed it's
not to say the film doesn't have some
dramatic moments it's just not
especially dramatic it's just enough so
that we want to be on their side when
they're flying around throwing swords
and breathing fire and doing all the
stuff we want to see an authority the
laughs make us enjoy them more the
effects show the cool things they can do
while they're making us laugh so when we
get to the really big action sequences
we're entirely on board it's not Lord of
the Rings or Lawrence of Arabia but I
don't think it's really meant to be it's
supposed to be a comic book movie a
comic book movie of gods fighting each
other and blowing shit up and saying
cool one-liners at the center of it are
the incredibly charming characters the
one good thing in every single Thor
movie is always Thor himself
Chris Hemsworth is just so charming
whether he has to be funny whether he
has to be bad as whether he has to be
big whether he has to be subtle
he works for whatever is needed it's
also great to see Eric Bana focused on I
feel like this is the Hulk movie we also
really deserve that never got it's
interesting that he would actually want
to stay The Hulk for a long time like he
chose to do so and when he doesn't want
to change back into the Hulk again he's
constantly surrounded by people who
glorify it they praise the monster they
praise the violence which is actually
kind of an interesting commentary when
you think about it he's trying to run
away from being the awful beast in a
world where everybody wants him to be
the awful beast
you could almost argue that's the Hulk's
complicated movie history in a nutshell
I also like this drunk bounty hunter
who's got a real tragic backstory but
still gets a lot of good laughs as well
the only problem I have is this she's
supposed to be a literal fall down drunk
why does she always look that good
should her hair be a little messed up or
a little sloppy if you can't even stand
have you got your eyeliner or that
perfect I guess I shouldn't talk when
you seek a planchette throughout this
entire picture good god
this design is crazy and her acting
totally backs it it's big it's loud it's
intense
it's totally having fun with every
moment I guess if I had any criticism it
would have been that the film could have
been cut down by a good 15 20 minutes it
didn't need to be this long I also argue
that maybe a little bit more drama would
have been welcomed but I am still happy
with what we got especially compared
with the other thor ragnarok is a big
goofy movie in all the right ways it's
got the charm it's got the action it's
got the cool effects
it's my definition of a good pop
it's just enough to get invested but you
don't have to think too hard about it
either it's just stupid fun that took a
lot of smart planning to accomplish
cross the Rainbow Bridge and enjoy your
hammer time
[Music]